[Musique]
il
ce matin était organisé une balade sur
le thème de la biodiversité au coeur du
quartier l'école polytechnique pour un
certain nombre d'aménagements été
réalisés en faveur de
l'accueil la circulation des espèces sur
ce quartier la prise en compte de la
biodiversité est intervenu très tôt dans
le dans la réflexion autour du
développement de ce quartier de façon à
préserver des circulations et des
espaces qu'ils soient favorables à la
biodiversité
ça veut dire
des espaces ample et fonctionnel qui
permet d'accueillir un maximum d'espèces
les plus original possible
et puis ensuite de faire en sorte que ce
quartier soit perméable aux circulation
des espèces pour garantir l'accueil d'un
maximum d'espèces qui étaient parfois
présentes avant la création du quartier
qu'on souhaite maintenir
et puis l'accueil de nouvelles espèces
nouveaux cortèges d'espèces qui peuvent
se développer à la faveur des
aménagements qui sont réalisés comme les
aménagements de gestion des eaux
pluviales par exemple prennent beaucoup
de place dans le quartier mais qui sont
aussi des milieux des nouveaux
écosystèmes qui sont créés et donc
qu'ils sont favorables à l'accueil des
espèces spécifiques des oiseaux liés à
l'eau par exemple
sterne pierregarin qu'on peut retrouver
régulièrement sur ce secteur mais aussi
des petits limicoles comme le chevalier
guignette par exemple qui apprécient ce
genre d' espace donc à l'échelle du
quartier un certain nombre d'habitats
nouveaux ont été créés et qui
constituent des engagements de la part
de l'aménageur public qui sont là pour
être présent sur le long terme donc ils
sont entretenus dans un premier temps le
temps de la vie et du développement du
quartier par l'aménageur public
à terme c'est bien sûr des espaces qui
sont amenés à perdurer au delà
quand ce quartier sera achevée mais
qu'il vivra aussi avec ses populations
et donc des espaces qui sont amenés à
vivre sur le long terme
il ya des engagements de d'entretien
pendant une trentaine d'années mais bien
sûr elles ont vocation à durer et bien
que longtemps que ça avec une gestion
par la collectivité
et puis bien sûr l'appropriation par les
par les habitants de ces milieux leur
connaissance et la diffusion de leurs de
leur intérêt l'appropriation de ces
milieux par les populations et
par la collectivité
[Musique]